dernier sujet les prix littéraires après
la qualif française qui récompense et
laurent binet pour son roman civilations
chez grasset la semaine dernière ce sont
les jury goncourt et renaudot qui ont
annoncé à midi leurs lauréats
jean paul dubois pour tous les hommes
n'habite pas le monde de la même façon
aux éditions de l'olivier et sylvain
tesson pour la panthère des neiges aux
éditions gallimard et je signale aussi
notre ami eric neuhoff pour son pamphlet
chez albin michel très cher cinéma
français qui avaient également donc reçu
le prix renaudot essai j'aurais pu vous
a ajouté que sylvain tesson et demain
salle gaveau dans les grands noms du
figaro mais je ne le fais pas puisque
c'est déjà plein à craquer avant même
qu'il ait son renaudot alors un jour
posé la question à tous les 14 étapes
est ce que vous êtes plutôt bon coup
renault cette année là et les années
précédant billet pour kirby moi je suis
en général plutôt renault dacia bien
l'histoire du renaudot 1926 savez en
1906 mais les voilà les journalistes qui
attendent ne se dise on s'embête là on
va faire faire un prix et il en sommes
pris et puis et puis trois ans après
c'est marcel aymé qu'il a et puis encore
trois ans et céline donc moi je suis
plutôt enfin bon personnellement mais je
suis plutôt renaudot alors cette année
c'est la testostérone ces tessons c&c
nov c'est les mecs c'est vrai quoi c'est
marrant parce que on a d'un côté la
panthère des neiges exécrable l'autre
côté on a du bois très intérieur est
l'homme qui a raté sa vie qui rate tout
et c'est qu'ils nous racontent les
débats intérieurs très sophistiqué c'est
ma maison vous direz mais j'ai même
rater ma mort voilà c'est ça donc aussi
en tout cas il rate des choses non mais
en tout cas il va sur le terrain il va
pas très loin
voilà du bois il va à toulouse toulouse
attendu mais en tout cas c'est c'est ça
donc moi cette année pardoxalement je
ferai une exception on dirait plutôt sur
le bon cours ou et je crois didier
leschi écoutez franchement j'ai lu aucun
de ces livrets jeux mais en règle
générale goncourt c'est quelque chose
qui vous j'avais bien aimé
villard l'année dernière la régulière
non l'ordre du jour ne restait à deux
ans dernière ya deux ans voilà l'ordre
du jour j'ai bien aimé le sermon sur la
chute de rome si j'avais bien aimé faire
à rivaliser quand même les bons coups
reçus facilement surtout actes sud
et si je vous demande un renaudot en
revanche vous aurez du mal sur marne où
donc est ce qu'il ya eu on va dire je
vous lise et partant les bons coups
alexandre dumas la faille oui j'ai plus
de souvenirs de concours mais parce que
c'est des souvenirs de lecture pas très
anciennes notamment revoir là haut vers
lemaitre était quand même un grand
moment après je trouve que les deux
histoires raconte à chaque fois quelque
chose et que ce qu est cette capacité
qu'on a quand même en france à mettre
des coups de projecteur sur sur des bons
livres sur des volumes ya rarement de
l'est rarement de allah de choix qui
sont quand même complètement à côté de
la plaque ya parfois des livres plus
compliqué que d'autres cantons en termes
d'accès vous prenez les bienveillantes
par exemple qui était un truc improbable
comment est ce qu'on a pu arriver à
donner le prix goncourt à cette relaxe
sachant que c'est le seul éditeur qu'il
a pris du compte qu'ils y ont cours et
en même temps c'est un encouragement
fascinant de profondeur invraisemblable
en termes de travail qui a été réalisé
par som ii
donc voilà on a cette capacité voilà à
faire émerger des talents des plus maroc
moi je trouve que c'est ce qui est
intéressant cette année c'est que c'est
des romans qui sont très en phase avec
leur époque les deux raconte une partie
de nos problématiques à la fois sur
celui le renaudot où on est on retrouve
les les enjeux finalement de toile de
fond de douala de biodiversité etc et
l'autre qui nous fait voilà le coup de
la nostalgie du monde d'avant qui était
bien mieux
il n'empêche que ces voix là c'est des
thématiques qui sont fortes dans la
période d'un con qu'on traverse
aujourd'hui
alors il a fait hier une petite
polémique est toujours une polémique
cécile amélie nothomb v
le goncourt on entendait déjà quelques
critiques malveillants hurlait en dix
ans la littérature populaire à compenser
qu'elle aura en même temps s'arrêtait
bien qu'une femme et le goncourt parce
que c'est pas si fréquent que ça leur
style vous avez un avis tribu un prix à
une personne parce que c'est une femme
ou parce que c'est un homme et parce
qu'elle a du talent donc j'ose espérer
que le prix a été attribué à celui qui
avait écrit le plus beau livre
maintenant si on doit faire le concours
entre le renaudin renault dont et puis
le goncourt personnellement j'opterais
plutôt pour le renaudot pourquoi parce
que pour moi justement il ya ce côté un
peu transgressif un peu révolutionnaire
voilà on va faire notre notre propre
c'est notre gros sous et puis surtout
surtout parce que bas malheureusement le
concours est passé à côté de beaucoup de
beaucoup d'oeuvres célèbres
maintenant moi je ne suis pas une adepte
de ce genre de choses parce que j'aime
être assez libre dans le choix de mes
lectures canton des offres je les lis
gens trouvent je trouve toujours
beaucoup de plaisir mais c'est vrai que
quand moi je dois lire je lis
généralement de l'essai donc c'est pas
danser dans ses ouvrages là je vais
tomber ça cela dit si nous assistons
c'est à mi-chemin entre les seules leurs
enfants et par ailleurs le résultat
était pas révolutionnaire mais la
démarche mais puisqu'il n'était pas dans
la liste des finalistes donc le jury
renaudot fidèle à sa tradition a fait un
petit coup vraiment en 2007 c'était en
2007 où il avait mis pennac au dernier
moment contre et puis non
à une morte je crois je cherche son le
titre quelques années ils sont adeptes
des coups en tout cas dans les deux sauf
power c'est aussi un élément est un des
éléments du software français de la
culture
et ces prix là on a toujours un peu
d'attentisme en internationales agissent
plutôt une suite 20 ou 30 et aux
traductions dépannage et rayonner la
france personne le sang c'est aussi un
enjeu financier prévoit justement sûr
c'est intéressant c'est sur leboncoin
cette polémique c'est l'enjeu était
aussi là c'est à dire qu'elles vont
nommer un email avantage sexy amélie
nothomb à le goncourt
mettons de côté le fait que c'est une
femme c'est pas 500 mille quatre cent
mille cinq cent mille sept cent mille
huit cent mille neuf cent mille et donc
la libre et n'aura qu'à se réjouir parce
qu'il vendra deux fois plus de livres et
fera venir deux fois plus de gens donc
il y avait cet enjeu là mais est ce que
ce type d'enjeux financiers économiques
doit entraîner des comptes dans les
critères de choix d'un livre c'est toute
la question et nous en reparlerons
sûrement l'année prochaine c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui
point de vue merci à tous les quatre
vous retrouvez l'émission demain bien
entendu avec vincent roux aux commandes
bonsoir
[Musique]